keeping the arts alive here in las vegas
the pandemic has left many entertainers
struggling to stay afloat
so a special benefit was held tonight to
help them bounce back
madison kimbrough attended that welcome
back vegas event tonight she joins us
live from stoney's rock and country with
the latest
madison yeah sasha people got the
opportunity to watch these las vegas
entertainers perform
once again live for free as you can see
we're right here at stoney's rockin
country bar
this was an event meant to help
struggling las vegas artists bounce back
and book gigs once again take a look
with the entertainment industry taking
one of the biggest hits during the
pandemic
those in the performing arts need our
support more than ever
they are born entertainers that's what
they do they
that's their life that's their
livelihood
marty b who is no stranger to the
entertainment world of las vegas
worked decades in the trade show
industry and he knew he had to do
something for his
fellow entertainment performers it was
heartbreaking to see people entertaining
each other because they couldn't
entertain on stage
saturday night marty b's save our arts
foundation hosted welcome back las vegas
a live benefit concert
with the goal to raise money for these
struggling artists from comedy to
musical performances
artists shared how this year has
impacted them the last year has been
scary to go from nine shows a week
between my show
and the band to none to them maybe three
is you know it hurts your soul
especially as a performer
it's not just work for us we love what
we do it's been tough
it's been a struggle really hard but at
the same time you know it's
you just have to hang in there you know
whatever you know we're basically
gypsies
so we have to make it up as we go the
hope is that this event will be the
first of many
targeting those in the performing arts
industry and helping them get back on
their feet
and the welcome back vegas event is also
available on pay-per-view with the
proceeds going directly to the artist
tonight's admission was free and the
event lasted for about three hours
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now